[Music]
it's disrespectful grinding news oh my
cousin work ethic girl didn't grind it
hopefully the latter submitted by I need
to pee at night the blame light ten
tourists have been arrested in Cambodia
for pornographic dancing near a sacred
temple Oh what were they doing were they
doing the twerking next to Buddha no
granting a question where are they from
please my America
I feel like they're college kids like
stupid college kids you don't like to do
dumb thing Cambodia is some serious [ __ ]
I wasn't there for my church group and
it's just like their other they're doing
the two never know right yeah the
[ __ ] Charleston is insane they're
like that's too much gyration whoa whoa
whoa
get your sexual [ __ ] out of here no they
were from the UK New Zealand the
Netherlands it's at our group qk2
Canadian all Contiki come on it's a
total group they didn't mention a crew
spontaneously dancing someplace without
music but their age from 19 to 35 so it
sounds like it sounds exactly continue
would never dance in Cambodia period
doesn't seem like a place where you
should dance
you shouldn't dance in Cambodia we all
agree yeah yeah Cambodia is dangerous
dude this is the name Cambodia like
makes me go oh [ __ ] I better I better be
careful I just better not be there alone
right yeah it looks I'm legit [ __ ] out
there though yeah so these tourists
that's really great though yeah so they
were partying it up in these photos
surface like Oh
so they got two guys two girls hetero
it's just all kinds so doing the
missionary you ever do that one they
arrested ten Fortner I've never laid
down on a desk oh my god look at that
girl in that guy's bit like her ass is
on his face but she looks like she
really doesn't know what she's doing
though she's defecating in his mouth it
just looks like the most awkward type of
grinding ever wear usually please you
stop yeah looks like he fell on the
ground there so she's chill trying to
make it look like they're dancing cuz
they're in a dancing competition
yeah what I mean was this at a Buddhist
temple or something or woman well yeah
would they plan music yeah it's like
monks chanting a chit if that was like
15 year old kids they'll freak to
anything
they'll freak - elevator music that's
true they will and if it's a [ __ ]
Christian group and they're like going
they don't they went somewhere it's over
dude
those mission trips ball-gag and all
they everything can't wait right there
more like the crazier the better oh yeah
that's the best place to get some plus
Arabs
are some of the horniest places on earth
on the earth I will say that is very
very true yeah a lot of people get in
trouble during those little retreats
yeah my friend told me that him and his
girl that they hope he hooked up with
had a huge rub fest in the airplane and
they've covered that blanket he said a
rub yeah masturbation well it's the
worst because you don't nobody gets to
come yeah right so you just sort of
grinding on each other forever and
nothing happens right at least if you
[ __ ] you get to come I think that's good
enough yeah there was one of the levels
eleven older Church guys they were like
one of those small group leaders and
then he [ __ ] one of the younger girls
at one of the retreats and then it was
so [ __ ] bad because like so my dad
was one of the Deacons at the church and
that issue came up to him and so he
wanted to talk to his parents the
parents about before anybody else heard
about it so he goes hey I just want to
talk to you about this like this
situation that happened with your son
they're like impossible he would never
do that type of [ __ ] and they started
like yelling at my dad as [ __ ] he was
like well I was just gonna tell you guys
first before it goes anywhere else cuz I
want to get out here you know cuz I
don't want anybody else to find out
about it but they were so adamant about
defending you know the [ __ ]
I love parents who think they know their
kids sexual [ __ ] I know and it's so
weird because she was pregnant right
after
it was great you don't know anything
about your kids sexual [ __ ] but opposite
as soon as they're born
you [ __ ] home yeah skeptical mm-hmm
yeah they were so adamant that they do
seven George son was a saint it's like
do you know anything about your child
your child is a piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's all sons done I don't know if he
figures is but in the shower right
you're cleaning that's what you're doing
[Laughter]
cleaning Jean personal hygiene wanna
talk about it guys let's move it on
shower Ilana I do yes she knows it's
cleaning right it's cleaning yeah yeah
like he's bluffing on a scratch in his
car he's trying to rub body butter yeah
it's like oh I don't know about that
you bleached that [ __ ] no my just every
single wrinkle yes get rid of it just
trying to polish all penny at all you
guys are asking where this was right
near a temple so it was near the anger
anger walk ankle what oh I like that
Angkor Wat that is beautiful nice and so
where what are they like next to the
tree and the shot at go to Cambodia near
it you know it's funny there's a lot of
here specifically but it was like in the
city mirador some [ __ ] in the in the
temple their sculptures of light orgies
happening is it really but naked ladies
with big ol boobies here in the Inca
life we got cities man yeah I don't like
this and then they're like [ __ ] like
titties hanging out and like they're
dancing and then it's like they're doing
it yeah I don't know what it's for but
they they been they used to be cool when
that was time you know so maybe what all
those students were doing was just like
bringing some ancient [ __ ] no one said
they were students do you think there
are all excuse me tourists do you think
that our modern porn will one day be
seen is art it would be like ancient
Kama Sutra paintings and sure maybe I
don't think so because it's a required a
art well actually but see did this you
could argue that too it's like they just
drew bunch of teens on wall yeah but it
wasn't for the sake of it was they call
it for fertility the other one is just
the point we're assuming that them and
all
take sound like sculpt the titty out of
like stone yeah that's true it does take
a little bit of time I think that's what
they used to jack off to they were to go
to the temple and they would see titties
and oh just for sure I you know there
was there was us not state-sponsored
what he prosecute prostitution but it
was like um it was like religious
sponsored prostitution in Sumeria one of
the oldest oldest uh ancient
civilizations known to man what was the
justification for so during fertility
seas are during a harvest season um I
think it's the first daughter or the
youngest daughter of every household
would go to the temple and they would be
sex priests ist's and then you would pay
tribute and you would have sex and then
you would go back home and then
hopefully you get a good harvest because
you had sex with the fertility princess
or that was just a better time yeah I
mean that's that's really a religious
sponsored brothel that's dope that's
horrible
why you don't want a good harvest people
start yeah you want people not I don't
want a lot of dick in me what the [ __ ]
but it was an honor it was an honor to
be where your ancestors thought was an
honor yeah yeah it was an honor to be a
priestess I want my [ __ ] to look
beautiful also no and I I mean
personally I would just do a rain dance
yeah yeah yeah I would join you with
that [ __ ] I'm like no keep your [ __ ]
meats up because uh yeah I don't want to
pay for [ __ ]
look at him covering their dicks yeah
that's the biggest like I was funny of
women to go around truth they look so
vanilla and and like straightedge that
you were not imagined first those are
the worst ones actually yeah the one on
the left looks like he's a little
douchebag though that's why he's not
with the group yeah he thinks he's a
little bit edgy
he's the Fonzie other group yeah hey
what I started it the one the the
redheaded one looks like he dates Asian
girls that don't speak English he was
there on the tour he was there on the
tour for a wife yeah that's like he
teaches English in Taiwan or some [ __ ]
that's true you weren't a jackass Oh eat
stinky tofu you suck my dick
that's why there was who's enough emails
to go around that's why guys are like
bucket let's do it
no wait let's do know they would look
there's guy on guy yeah a lot of these
people isn't interested though go to
other picture this guy's two guys did
yeah look at that guy a guy with the
blue tank top in the ten that they've
been reporting that's okay yeah isn't
that a guy that's a guy on guy party
right she's got a nice dress well excuse
me because I don't know any difference
hey you don't know if there's the you
can't assume their gender that's all I'm
saying okay that that that she's a yeah
you can't flip it around you can't flip
it around you messed up let it go
right cuz fat people are ugly right
stuff fat people are not ugly you need
to start a charity is called family born
okay you're about at that level too
you're like you're not at the login Paul
that will be our I like thick oh no
there's two women my bed
anything yeah two women but Otto
that's a cuff it's dangerous when people
go to other countries and act like it's
America or Australia because it's you
know what can happen is like you could
get caned or something but in Angkor Wat
you can't like just I don't know cryin
dance remember the Australian kids that
that moved a little bit of coke and then
they got shot to death from the police
wait Australian police fired
no no they moved some they move some
cocaine to Indonesia and in the
Indonesian police stopped them and then
well they were removing cocaine out of
Indonesia to Australia and then they got
firing squad don't commit crime in
Indonesia in any other country yeah yeah
any other countries and America you're
pretty chill yeah watch document this
documentary called locked up abroad well
that'll scare you for days man if you're
gonna commit some real crimes go to
Canada that's pretty they're pretty
great about it
they apologize to you sorry we made you
do it right yes sweet it's like Sweden
you go to like murder somebody and then
you'll be out in two years and they'll
give you a job
Wow hander give you a house yeah
basically like apartment it's like a
golf boy they really believe in
rehabilitation like it's not just like
saying they're gonna you know they eat
it stones on your back why do you have
like they treat you like a [ __ ] human
being there but their government
we believe in rehabilitation here to
them it's like we're gonna give you
seven life sentences I love that [ __ ]
here's you're going to you're in for 233
years
okay I'm gonna die real bad I get it
yeah oh yeah
[Music]